it's painful
to understand how much
of what you're doing isn't productive so
i'll give you an example so i've done
this a couple of times with classrooms
full of students usually when i'm
lecturing about career development say
okay
how much time do you waste so then i get
the class to vote how many of you waste
uh 10 hours a day it's like 10 of the
kids will put up their hands and it's
interesting because i don't define what
constitutes waste
i just asked the question so they're
diagnosing themselves right i'm not
saying you're wasting 10 hours a day i'm
just asking it's like given your own
attitude how much time are you wasting
10 hours a day it's like 10 of the
people put up their hands
well when you get to like six hours a
day eighty percent of the people put up
their hands so then we do the arithmetic
because i like doing arithmetic with
people people hate arithmetic but i like
doing it it's like okay six hours a day
it's 42 hours a week so let's call that
a work week 40 hours a week
let's say what's your time worth you're
a university student well it's certainly
worth minimum wage because obviously but
it's worth way more than that because
if you spend a productive hour when
you're 20
then you gain the benefits of that hour
for the rest of your life so there's the
compounding effect of time spent when
you're young so i say well let's assume
your time's worth 50 bucks an hour which
i think is an underestimate but whatever
let's call it 50. we call it 25 but
we'll call it 50. that's 2 dollars a
week you're wasting it's a hundred
thousand dollars a year
it's like how much better would your
life be if you weren't wasting a hundred
thousand dollars a year
it's like what is that over forty years
four million dollars it's like you're
rich you don't even know it
quit wasting time
by your own definition
it's like people shake their heads like
i never thought about it that way it's
like yeah
think about it that way don't waste your
damn life
and you know when people do that kind of
wasting they actually hate it
you know and so they're watching youtube
videos say but but not ones that are
good for them although sometimes they
will do that but just
browsing in that kind of mindless way
that you do when you're not paying
attention and you're trying to kill time
and
people doing that they feel bad they get
depressed they feel anxious they can't
get away from it they feel kind of
quasi-addicted what are they saying
about social media now it's a huge issue
with young kids absolutely but there's
this feeling of kind of internal rot and
corruption that goes along with it it's
like yeah well you're wasting your life
it's like so it's painful it's painful
to recognize that then it's painful to
think oh my god
look how undisciplined i am
i don't know anything i can't use a
schedule i can't i can't stick to a
calendar i don't have any aims i don't
know anything about the world
right and maybe there's a part of me
that's bitter because i haven't got
everything already and i'd like just
like to say to hell with it that's the
recognition of the union's shadow it's
like that's what makes you vicious and
and and untrustworthy all of that no one
wants to look at that and no bloody
wonder
you